[تصفيق]
أعلم أنكم جميعًا سترغبون في الاستماع إلى
وزير الخارجية الجديد هنري
كيسنجر الذي لم يكن في حاجة حقًا إلى
تقديمه على المسرح العالمي مرة أخرى.
كيسنجر أشهر رجل دولة في
النصف الأخير من
القرن العشرين، وهو مشهور ومثير للجدل.
سيكون له أي معنى لأن
مستشار الأمن القومي لريتشارد نيكسون ووزير
الخارجية كان يتمتع بسلطة
هائلة ونفوذ موثوق به لدرجة أن
كيسنجر هو الذي ذهب إلى الصين
في مهمة سرية لاستكشاف
الانفتاح التاريخي للعلاقات الأمريكية مع
الصين الشيوعية.  يكون
وحيدًا في بكين دون أي اتصالات،
وبالتالي إذا لم يكن يعرف
عقل نيكسون، فقد يفعل
أشياء حمقاء في البداية، كانت هناك مخاوف من أن
تؤثر مباراة تبادل بينج بونج بين الولايات المتحدة والصين على المناورة السياسية عالية المخاطر بين
الحين والآخر
يحدث شيء ما في
الدبلوماسية التي  يتجاوز صياغة
البرقيات التي تزايدت فيها الخسائر في فيتنام مع
سيطرة الفيتناميين على الأراضي، حيث
اعتقد نيكسون وكيسنجر غير الدبلوماسي أن المزيد من
قصف الشمال من شأنه أن يساعد، وأود أن
أوصي بعد ذلك
بأن يوافق كيسنجر في غضون 48 ثانية على
القصف السري للوحدات الفيتنامية الشمالية في
كمبوديا دون
موافقة الكونجرس كما كان يقول في بعض الأحيان.  يتعين على
رجال الدولة أن يختاروا من بين الشرور
التنازلات الأخلاقية في الصراعات الفوضوية. وقد حصل
كيسنجر ونظيره الفيتنامي
لو داك تو على جائزة نوبل للسلام
لدورهما في التفاوض على وقف
إطلاق النار. ولا بد لي من القول إنني لم
أتعامل قط مع مجموعة من الناس
غادرين مثل الشمال
أصر كيسنجر على أن المشاكل على
الجبهة الداخلية تضر بفرص النجاح
في فيتنام. لقد خسرنا الحرب لأننا
كنا
منقسمين وأيضًا لأننا لم نكن
متأكدين جدًا مما أردناه،
دعم كيسو للجيش الشعبي في تشيلي والرجال الأقوياء العسكريين الموالين للولايات المتحدة
في أجزاء أخرى من فيتنام.
العالم درو انتقادات اعتقال هنري
كيسنجر بتهمة ارتكاب جرائم حرب
سيتم الطعن في إرث كيسنجر بعد عقود
عندما أدلى بشهادته في الكونجرس عن عمر يناهز
91 عامًا. نشأ كيسنجر في ألمانيا مع
غيوم الحرب التي تحيط بعائلته عندما
كان عمره 15 عامًا، حوالي نصف الأشخاص الذين ذهبت إليهم
إلى المدرسة مع ونحو 13 فردًا من
عائلتي ماتوا في
معسكرات الاعتقال، وزير خارجية يهودي
كان يستمع لاحقًا إلى رئيسه وهو
ينتقد القادة اليهود الأمريكيين، لقد حان
الوقت اللعين الذي يدرك فيه اليهودي في
أمريكا شخصًا أمريكيًا
جيدًا، لا أستطيع ذلك.  أنا أتفق معك أكثر، لقد
سمعت فقط تعليقات معادية للسامية عندما
هاجمته مجموعة يهودية بسبب
شيء فعله في الشرق الأوسط.
قام كيسنجر بما أصبح
يعرف بالدبلوماسية المكوكية للفصل بين القوات
الإسرائيلية والعربية مما مهد
الطريق لاتفاقيات السلام المستقبلية.  عندما
استقال نيكسون من منصبه كرئيس،
بقي كيسنجر في منصب وزير الخارجية جيرالد فورد، وكان
رأيه لا يزال مطلوبًا على نطاق واسع من
قبل الحكومات والشركات
بعد ترك المنصب العام، فأنت تريد أن
تترك بلدك أفضل مما
وجدته، ولا يوجد شيء في
الحياة الخاصة يمكنك القيام به هذا
كانت هناك وظيفة واحدة مثيرة للاهتمام ومرضية،
قال كيسنجر إنه لم يقم بها مطلقًا في
حياته، وهي المذيع الرياضي ديريك، الذي
لعب دور الدبلوماسي العالمي
في بعض أكبر المباريات في التاريخ.